olá boa noite tudo bem gente eu preciso
fazer isso eu preciso me acalmar
você olha pra vocês a gente tá junto né
se eu ficar aqui fingindo que eu também
não vai ser de verdade
bom vamos lá e se eu disser pra vocês
que a vida é um processo criativo a qual
questão se está tentando responder o
processo criativo é uma jornada em busca
de uma nova resposta no início dessa
jornada
uma pergunta a ser respondida a linha de
chegada a melhor solução que foi capaz
de criar entre uma ponte em outra
diversas etapas que começam com uma fase
de pesquisa é uma pesquisa que vai
levantar todas as informações
disponíveis sobre o assunto
você vai conhecer melhor o problema para
depois entrar na geração de alternativa
será alternativa nada mais é do que
criar o maior número de possibilidades
que você dá conta para aí
na sequência você pegar aquela ou
aquelas que têm o maior potencial e dar
um formato para ela esse formato vai ser
importante etapa de protótipo ação
protótipo aparece algo difícil mas na
verdade significam materializar a sua
ideia trazê la para a realidade pode ser
um formato um pouco diferente pode ser
um material é um pouco diferente
o importante é que esse formato seja
disponível para as pessoas testarem no
teste é que a sua ideia vai ser vista na
prática ela funciona o salão funciona
para pôr fim a gente chegar na validação
e aí na validação é que entendi essa é
realmente a melhor opção já facilitei
centenas de jornadas como essa nos
últimos anos e foi daí que nasceu essa
teoria a vida é ou se parece com um
grande processo criativo é isso que vou
tentar mostrar a partir de agora tudo
como eu disse começa com a pergunta
uma questão que pede uma nova resposta e
na vida tem duas coisas que nos
impulsiona
criar um novo os sonhos e os incômodos
sonho é uma imagem projetada de um
futuro desejado incômodos são coisas que
nascem dentro da gente e começam a
crescer e alertar a gente de que do
jeito que está não dá para continuar
esquece essa história de zona de
conforto
se tivesse mesmo confortável não fazia
sentido nenhum eu mudar de lugar
na maioria das vezes da inércia não é
uma escolha
a descrença na capacidade de se
reinventar
é o medo de mudar e ficar pior do que já
está
o problema é que a vida está pedindo pra
gente se reinventar o tempo inteiro
quando tinha dois anos de formado era
sócio do escritório de design
a gente tava indo bem a gente tem
clientes a gente tinha pessoas que
trabalhavam com a gente a gente uma sala
mas eu também tinha uma angústia
crescendo dentro de mim
ela estava ficando cada vez maior
já não ia trabalhar mais com a mesma
vontade que eu ia no início e que antes
gostava muito de fazer das suas e
sofrido
foi daí que eu me dei conta do que eu
fazia antes com prazer
eu passei a fazer por inércia a maior
justificativa que a gente dá pra inércia
são as nossas restrições
a gente tem limites mas olha eu não
conheço nenhum processo criativo que não
tenha restrições
aliás vocês conhecem alguma vida que não
as tenha podem ser grande podem ser
pequenas podem ser visíveis com aquelas
que só você sabe pode ser inclusive
aquelas que não têm coragem de dizer em
voz alta nem mesmo de pesquisar no
google
pra mim existem duas maneiras de lidar
com as restrições como obstáculos
insuperáveis ou como convites a
experimentar novos caminhos
elas não atrapalham o processo criativo
na verdade elas fazem existir se não
tivesse restrição estava fácil para
pegar a primeira alternativa primeira
resposta e seguir em frente
quando me tornei tomei essa decisão não
é de sair do escritório uma das minhas
sócias me chamou para conversar ela
virou pra mim e perguntou você tem
certeza do que está fazendo
se tem alguma coisa em mente você vai
casar se acabou de comprar um carro está
bom e as minhas restrições
eu não podia tirar um ano sabático
eu não podia ficar muito tempo
investindo em algo que não me desce
retorno financeiro mas naquela altura do
campeonato também não podia ficar parado
no mesmo lugar
eu entendi que definitivamente era hora
de criar novas possibilidades fazer
design me ensinou a criar alternativas
ao invés de acreditar que só tem uma
chance
aquelas pessoas que você julga que tem
dez melhores que você só fazem uma coisa
diferente elas criam mais alternativas a
esse item ficou célebre por uma teoria o
que pouca gente sabe é que ele criou
mais 248 publicações algumas obras de
arte tornar um picasso extremamente
famoso mas por trás delas existem outras
5 mil
talvez o único lugar do mundo em que
quantidade é igual a qualidade seja no
processo criativo quanto mais
alternativas você tiver mais chances de
chegar onde deseja
se você acredita que só tem uma chance
encontra obstáculo que separa se você
quer e acredita que pode gerar
alternativas até chegar ao resultado
desejado você sempre segue em frente
mas eu sei eu vejo isso quase todos
os dias gerar alternativas dá medo
porque é uma etapa do processo criativo
feita de caos e de ambiguidade não tem
linha reta
nem estrada finalizada por isso dá medo
e ciúme perder quando eu sair do
escritório de design
eu realmente não sabia para onde estava
indo e foi por isso que me permite
experimentar
eu comecei a escrever eu participei de
projetos como voluntários mas eu também
fiz filas para pagar as contas mas o
tempo foi passando e eu ainda não tinha
encontrado o meu caminho aí bateu medo
nessa fase
esquece o controle e confia no processo
é mesmo uma questão de fé
toda vez que eu me perco uma coisa boa
me acha a pessoa que tinha me chamado
para se inscrever como voluntário no
projeto me chamou para um outro projeto
desta vez remunerado em que além de
escrever eu precisava pesquisar
tendências
isso me chamou a atenção e me abriu um
novo caminho
todo mundo que descobriu algo novo um
minuto antes estava perdido na época dos
grandes descobrimentos do meio do
atlântico pra frente já não tinha má pa
por isso que você for pesquisar e ler os
diários de bordo de pedro álvares cabral
ou cristóvão colombo
você vai entender que pouco antes já
está a terra nova eles estavam
literalmente perdidos
foi assim com os grandes navegadores
assim comigo talvez seja assim com você
um caminho a uma marca criada pelos pés
de outras pessoas
como diria maria rezende uma querida e
jovem poeta estradas cheias de setas não
dão entre as desertas
se você quer chegar a um lugar novo
talvez vai precisar pisar onde ninguém
ainda pisou a minha melhor alternativa
acredita em era mais improvável
um designer e decidiu escrever no
processo criativo é muito importante
ao gerar alternativas está sempre aberto
porque a inspiração pode vir de qualquer
pessoa e de qualquer lugar e tem número
um da cartilha dos narcóticos anônimos
só depende de você mas sozinho você não
consegue pessoas que pensam diferente de
nós
enxergam partes do mapa que ainda não
fomos capazes de ver ninguém te dizendo
que precisa ir lá pisar naquele lugar
só que é uma decisão inteligente pelo
menos conhecer saber que existe a maior
parte do meu aprendizado veio de outras
pessoas
foi do encontro com elas eu descobrir
novos caminhos
eu tenho certeza que vocês olharem para
trás vocês vão perceber o mesmo de
determinadas pessoas não tivessem
sentado na vida de vocês
talvez o caminho que você tivesse sido
completamente diferente
minha professora de informática da 8ª
série não tivesse me dito que eu era bom
com computadores que eu devia fazer um
curso técnico talvez não tivesse feito
uma amiga no último dia de estágio do
curso técnico não tivesse me dado um
livro específico de presente
talvez eu nunca tivesse conhecido uma
esposa
se eu não tivesse sido sócio daquele
escritório de design
eu não teria conhecido sérgio abreu
comigo uma nova empresa e acreditou no
design que queria escrever aprender a
escrever códigos me ajudou a lidar com
os erros como parte do processo e ir e
vir quantas vezes forem necessárias
isso significa que pode gerar um milhão
de alternativas até dá certo e vai dar
se ainda não deu certo é porque o
processo criativo ainda não terminou
o mais legal é conseguir perceber que o
que faz o seu caminho ser só seu
são as voltas que teve que dá eu sei
escrever códigos consertar computadores
você criar identidade visual
hoje eu não faço mais nada disso mas
tudo isso me faz fazer melhor o que eu
faço um desvio um erro tem que ser
vistos como perda de tempo e sim como
mais experiência mais repertório e mais
aprendizado
agora e quando diversas alternativas que
parecem boas quais que deve escolher a
pergunta na verdade é outra não precisa
escolher só uma
porque você precisa escolher só uma
a gente passa a vida inteira acreditando
que a gente precisa ser isso ou aquilo
não dá pra fazer isso e aquilo outro dia
fui fazer um mapa astral e astróloga
virou pra mim falou o seguinte olha no
seu campo profissional eu não consigo
entender que você fez
você tinha alguns caminhos muito fortes
aqui se eu pudesse designer se podia ser
gestor de uma empresa se podia dar a
aula ela parou e falou assim afinal de
contas o que se resolveu
eu falei que não conseguiu ver que na
verdade eu escolhi os três eu tenho uma
amiga em um determinado ponto da sua
bem-sucedida carreira de jornalista
achou que precisava mudar de rumo
ela parou pensou bastante e entendeu que
o estava chamando ela naquele momento
era gastronomia mas ela ainda mau
jornalismo é uma pessoa virou pra ele
perguntou mas o que você precisa deixar
de ser jornalista para trabalhar com
gastronomia
não dá para fazer as duas coisas ao
mesmo tempo e dava ela não fez isso
abandonando tudo que ela tinha
construído até ali
ela também tinha restrições ela criou um
projeto paralelo unindo gastronomia e
jornalismo era o protótipo dela do
tamanho e do formato que cabiam naquele
momento era só o começo
o protótipo virou um livro virou um
curso procuradoria de uma exposição
virou coisas que ela nunca havia
imaginado
um dos nossos maiores desafios quando
está criando algo novo é querer fazer
algo grande demais um sofisticado demais
logo no início
e aí pode ser que nunca esteja bom o
suficiente pra gente começar
pode ser que passe muito tempo ea gente
desista
mas pra mim o maior desafio mesmo do
processo criativo é você nunca se
esquecer do que te fez começar a
pergunta inicial é que te disse você foi
bem sucedido ou não é fácil de se
esquecer disso e começar a seguir à
métrica de sucesso dos outros
dinheiro poder e status cargo salário
número de funcionários faturamento
eu mesmo já me enganei por diversas
vezes e sofri quando percebi que eu tava
indo numa direção completamente
diferente daquilo que eu não tinha me
perguntado
é por isso que eu realmente quero
compartilhar com vocês
é uma pergunta que a gente deve todos os
dias para esse fazer a qual questão eu
tou mesmo tentando responder
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]